ONLY PEOPLE LIKE THAT CARE WHAT
COLOR YOU ARE BECAUSE BY
DIVIDING US THEY BECOME MORE
COLORFUL.
POWERFUL.
LET’S HOPE THAT ENDS SOON.
THIS WEEKEND IS EASTER BUT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN THIS COUNTRY
THE COUNTRY’S CHRISTIANS CAN’T
CELEBRATE WITH ONE ANOTHER EVEN
IF THEY WANT TO.
MOST GOVERNMENTS WILL NOT ALLOW
THEM TO GATHER IN CHURCHES.
MISSISSIPPI IS ON LOCKDOWN AT
ALL NONESSENTIAL BUSINESSES ARE
CLOSED, WHICH MEANS LIQUOR
STORES ARE STILL OPEN BECAUSE
THEY ARE ESSENTIAL BUT CHURCHES
ARE NOT.
THE KING JAMES BIBLE BAPTIST
CHURCH HAS BEEN TRYING TO HOLD
DRIVE-IN SERVICES WHICH MEANS
PARISHIONERS REMAIN IN THEIR
CARS BUT COPS SHOWED UP AND
RATED IT.
>> KING JAMES BIBLE BAPTIST
CHURCH WHERE I’M THE PASTOR OF
THE CHURCH.
I’M A GOOD CITIZEN.
I’M NOT BREAKING NO LAW OR
SELLING DRUGS, I’M JUST
PREACHING THE WORD OF GOD AND
LOOK AT ALL THESE POLICE CARS
HERE.
SPEAK ON IT THAT JAMES HAMILTON
YOU HEARD ON THE TAPE.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON
TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
FIRST PASTOR, WHAT EXACTLY WERE
YOU DOING WRONG?
>> WE WEREN’T DOING ANYTHING
WRONG.
WE WERE ABIDING BY THE CDC
GUIDELINES THAT THE CITY HAD PUT
IN PLACE ALSO, IN THE STATE OF
MISSISSIPPI.
MEMBERS OF THE CHURCH WERE
INSIDE OF THEIR CARS AND HAD THE
WINDOWS UP, AND I WAS PREACHING
THE WORD OF GOD.
SO NO ONE WAS OUTSIDE.
ALSO WE HAD CARS AT A DISTANCE
AND SO LEGALLY WE WEREN’T DOING
ANYTHING WRONG.
WE WERE GOING BY THE CDC
GUIDELINES SO I DON’T UNDERSTAND
WHY THE POLICE OFFICERS WOULD
COME TO OUR CHURCH AND TRIED TO
BREAK IT UP.
>> Tucker: THAT’S TOTALLY
OUTRAGEOUS.
KELLY SHACKELFORD, I’M ASSUMING
WHEN THIS HAPPENED EVERY
CIVIL-RIGHTS GROUP IN AMERICA
JUMP TO THE PASTOR’S DEFENSE,
RIGHT?
>> I DON’T KNOW ABOUT THAT.
WE CERTAINLY DID, THE ORDER IN
GREENVILLE IS MASSIVELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT TARGETS CHURCHES IN A WAY
THAT IT TARGETS NO OTHER GROUPS.
CARS IN PARKING LOTS ARE FINE.
IT’S ONLY A CRIME IF THE CARS IN
THE PARKING LOT ARE AT THE
CHURCH PARKING LOT.
I MEAN LOOK AT LAST NIGHT, YOU
HAD PROBABLY SIX OR SEVEN CARS
THERE FOR THE CHURCH AND YET
THEY WERE SURROUNDED BY POLICE.
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
VIDEO BUT ONE OF THE POLICE
OFFICERS CAME UP TO PASTOR
HAMILTON AND SAID, BECAUSE OF
THAT LOCAL ORDER IN GREENVILLE,
MISSISSIPPI, THAT HIS RIGHTS
WERE SUSPENDED.
THOSE WERE THE SPECIFIC WORDS
THAT HE USED.
LIKE YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
ARE GONE NOW.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT COUNTRY HE
THINKS HE IS LIVING IN BUT THE
RIGHTS AREN’T SUSPENDED.
I WOULD JUST TELL ANY CHURCH
THAT HAS ANY OF THESE ISSUES, WE
HAVE A LOT OF THIS INFORMATION.
GO TO FIRST LIBERTY.ORG.
IT WILL TELL YOU THAT YOU DO
HAVE RIGHTS.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO FOLLOW THE CDC
A GUIDELINES, WE DON’T WANT
PEOPLE TO BE INJURED IN ANY WAY
BUT THAT DOESN’T GET PEOPLE TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST CHURCHES.
STATEMENT OF COURSE IT DOESN’T.
I’M NOT AGAINST LIQUOR STORES
BUT LIQUOR STORES DON’T ANSWER
THE QUESTION, WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU DIE.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO KNOW THEM.
HOW DO YOU FEEL THAT LIQUOR
STORES GET TO CONTINUE BUT YOU
CAN’T CELEBRATE EASTER IN CHURCH
CHURCH?
>> I THINK OF IT LIKE THIS.
I BELIEVE THAT LIQUOR AND BEER
HAVE KILLED MORE PEOPLE THAN THE
CORONAVIRUS EVER WOULD.
IT’S A SAD CASE IN AMERICA.
WHO WOULD HAVE EVER THOUGHT THAT
WE WOULD HAVE A GOVERNMENT IN
GREENVILLE THAT WOULD PASS SUCH
A LAW THAT WOULD ALLOW THE
LIQUOR STORE IS CURBSIDE
SERVICE, BUT WILL COME TO THE
CHURCH AND DISRUPTIVE CHURCH
SERVICE?
I WOULD HAVE NEVER DREAMED IN A
THOUSAND YEARS THAT AMERICA, THE
HOME OF THE BRAVE AND THE LAND
OF THE FREE EVER PASS THIS LAW
AND WOULD CONSIDER A LIQUOR
STORE ESSENTIAL BUT CHURCH
NONESSENTIAL.
I AM SHOCKED.
>> Tucker: SO 87,000 AMERICANS
DIED FROM ALCOHOL LAST YEAR.
THIS EPIDEMIC IS PROJECTED TO
KILL 60,000, AND YOU ARE
FACTUALLY RIGHT.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO OUT ON THIS.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW, AND IF YOU
KNOW THE NAME, DON’T SAY IT ON
THE AIR, BUT WHO MADE -- WHAT
POLITICIAN DECIDED THAT WAS A
GOOD IDEA?
>> ERIC SIMMONS, HE IS THE
MAYOR, HE’S A SUPPORTER OF
JOE BIDEN.
HE MADE A DECISION THAT BECAUSE
MOST OF THE VIRUS COMING WAS
LINKED TO THE CHURCHES, THAT’S
WHY HE CAME DOWN VERY HARD ON
THE CHURCHES DO NOT HAVE
DRIVE-IN SERVICES.
WHEN 20 PLUS CARS CAME TO OUR
CHURCH, WE FELT -- NOT JUST ME,
WE FELT INTIMIDATED.
WE FELT FRIGHTENED.
I HEARD ABOUT THIS COMING TO OUR
COUNTRY BUT I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD FEEL SO AFRAID AND MY
PEOPLE WOULD FEEL SO FRIGHTENED
AND DUMB LIKE INTIMIDATED BY
POLICE OFFICERS.
>> Tucker: YOU HEAR ABOUT
CIVIL RIGHTS VIOLATIONS, THIS IS
AN ACTUAL CIVIL RIGHTS